mr ruggs of course facing some very
serious charges that could result in
prison time and fines and joe moeller
continues our team coverage from the
clark county detention center with more
on what now could be awaiting rugs
after being treated for those
non-life-threatening injuries a few
blocks from here at umc he was brought
to the detention center where he is now
officially charged with duin reckless
driving
in the state of nevada this is a class b
felony and rugs could face anywhere from
two to 20 years in jail metro did not
release specifics about ruggs's injuries
from the crash people have been reacting
to news of the crash since it broke this
morning clark county commissioner
michael naff took to twitter outraged
over what has happened he has been
outspoken about the fatal crashes
happening in the valley lately i don't
care who you are there's no excuse for
this kind of behavior even more when
every single person in our community has
the option to take public transit if
you're drinking if you're abusing
substances every single person in our
community has the opportunity to call a
friend everyone in our community has the
option to take advantage of ride share
services
back out here live many fans of the
raiders have been reacting on social
media as well many people expressing
their disappointment with a decision
that was allegedly made last night to
get behind the wheel many people saying
the same thing is naft saying there are
plenty of options out there to take a
safe drive or a safe ride to get home
reporting live in downtown las vegas joe
molly live local now
henry ruggs is the now 26th nfl player
arrested this year that's according to a
usa today database and of the 26 players
arrested in 2020 six were for dui three
members of the las vegas raiders have
been arrested including running back
josh jacobs for dui in january and
cornerback kima sivaron who was arrested
for evading in texas that was in
february